>>My name is Virginia.
I'm fourteen years old.
I live in Camilla, Georgia,
and I get fun, entertainment,
and ease outta technology.
It just makes everything
a lot easier for me.
[Virginia playing piano].
>>Virginia: Camilla, Georgia,
is like a small southern town.
You know, we don't get
the newest stuff here,
and I definitely think people
overlook Camilla and the students
at Westwood, and people are surprised
to hear the achievements
we've had in computer class.
>>I first started using
computers about the seventh grade,
but I really started to get
the in depth view on technology
when I entered into eighth
grade with Miss Vicki's class.
>>-- how deep you can go into making
your character different, like--
>>Vicki: Okay, so how
you can customize it.
>>Virginia: Yeah, customizing
your character.
>>Vicki: I focus on teaching
them how to learn new software,
learning how to learn, using the
Wiki, how to blog effectively,
collaborating effectively,
being very comfortable
with just about any technology.
>>Virginia: She first
showed us how to blog.
>>Vicki: You have to click on
object and change your X, Y and Z.
>>Virginia: And then she went into
media and how you can edit videos,
and I just got so involved with it.
It was amazing.
>>Okay, here's my iGoogle page.
I have my Digi Teen Dream
Team stuff right here.
Digi Teen is a website my computer
teacher created and it was basically
for schools all around the world
to talk about digital citizenship
and do different blog posts with it.
I do about one blog a month,
with people on Digi Teen.
>>I'm a health freak, so, you know,
I have the world's healthiest
foods, food of the week.
Every other day, I like to go on
YouTube and see the top rated videos,
and then sometimes I'll
go to Spark Notes and read
up a coupla the books I'm studying.
I love to text message.
I use iTunes and that's how I get my
music and I share it with my friends.
I love to go on MySpace and Facebook
and play games like Guitar Hero.
[cross talk]
>>Virginia: It's my favorite game.
>>I love to play basketball.
>>Azalee: Virginia is an awesome kid.
There's a sweet, wonderful,kind
girl on the one side, and then,
the other side is this fierce
competitor, with a drive to succeed.
>>Virginia: I did really
good on defense today.
Someone baseline drived me a
coupla times, but-- I know, I know.
>>Mom, this ice is like frozen over.
>>Azalee: Why don't you [inaudible]
real quick and unfreeze it?
Shazam.
>>Virginia: When I get home
from basketball, I usually spend
about forty five minutes
checking my MySpace and Facebook,
and I usually just reply back to
friends' comments and I go look
at new pictures they've posted.
I love to take pictures.
I've tons of them.
>>Vicki: The thing that
makes Virginia very unique
that really impressed me when we
did our digital citizenship project,
was that she realized that she was
on Facebook for too much every day,
more than four hours a day.
>>Virginia: I realized I was
being very unhealthy online.
I started losing my color
in my face and I started,
you know, eating differently.
It was really weird.
So I was like, this is not good.
>>Azalee: They had a fast at our
church, that everyone was asked
to give something up for three
weeks, and Virginia saw this
as an opportunity to
reflect on the fact
that she was wired three hours
a day, and so she gave it up.
>>Vicki: I think that that shows
a lot of maturity in ninth grade
to keep that balance,
because technology is great,
but we also have a real life to live
and technology should improve our
lives, not take away from our lives.
>>Virginia: Okay, when everybody gets
in their wigwams, raise your hand.
>>I'm teaching young elementary
kids how to stay safe online.
>>Do you think there can be bad
people that would try and hurt you
on a website called Wiggi World?
>>I really wanted to make a
difference with that situation,
so I found this website called Wiggi
World, and I was like, "Miss Vicki,
this would be a great thing to do."
We just got a class going and
we're just teaching them, you know,
the little aspects of digital
citizenship that can go a long way.
>>Things you think you should
keep private to yourself online,
like not tell a stranger,
even if they ask?
Mm-hmm.
>>Your email address.
>>Virginia: You would not
tell your email address.
What else?
>>Where you live.
>>Virginia: Good job.
>>The kids have loved Wiggi World.
They don't really look
at it as learning.
They just look at it
as playing, you know.
>>Do you think we should give
them our cell phone number?
>>Everybody: No.
>>Virginia: No.
>>I've learned from the experience
of teaching how naive young kids
in the fourth grade are to
technology, the dangers of it.
>>Do you have any pets?
Do you think that would
be an okay question?
>>Vicki: Digital citizenship is
>>one of the most misunderstood,
under appreciated topics
in terms of education in schools.
Here in the south, we say a little
bit of dirt is good for your health.
If you want to raise an unhealthy
child, you put them in a bubble
and you never let them
get exposed to germs.
But no filter is going
to ever be perfect.
>>Virginia: What is your real name?
No, that's not a good question.
>>Vicki: I engage my
students in becoming teachers,
because it's presentation
skills and it's leadership.
But if you want to truly know
something, if you have to teach it,
then you become an expert.
>>Virginia: I just love to get up
there and, you know, teach the kids.
>>These things are very important.
You need to remember them as
long as you use a computer.
>>Miss Vicki has, you know, made
me see technology in such a new,
different light, and she's just
introduced me to the vast majority
of technology, not just cell phones
and computers, but, you know,
blogging and actually reaching out
to help people through technology.
I get to meet so many
new people and, you know,
share with them my
views on everything.
I do think digital
technology's improving my life.
>>My mom was very against
cell phones.
She hated them.
We finally talked her into getting a
cell phone, 'cause we could never get
in touch with her, and it's
been so much easier for her.
And I always have to show
her new things to do with it.
She always like, "I don't know what
to do on this darn thing," you know.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org